three weeks ago the uk led 41 states
to refer these atrocities to the
international criminal court
we're providing additional funding to
the icc
the uk military and police are providing
technical assistance the investigations
and the metropolitan police war crimes
unit have commenced the collection of
evidence
we're working very closely with the
ukrainian government on this
we've appointed former icc judge
howard morrison as an independent
adviser to the ukrainian prosecutor
general
and today i can announce that we're
launching a 10 million pound civil
society fund to support organizations in
ukraine including those helping the
victims of conflict-related sexual
violence
we will not rest until these criminals
have been brought to justice
we are clear
that after these appalling crimes russia
has no place
on the human rights council
and it is the responsibility
of the uk and our allies and that's what
dimitro and i have discussed today
to step up our support for our brave
ukrainian friends
that means more weapons
and more sanctions
putin must lose in ukraine
later this week the g7 foreign ministers
and the nato foreign ministers will meet
we need to announce a tough new wave of
sanctions
the reality is that money is still
flowing from the west into putin's war
machine and that has to stop
in brussels i will be working with our
partners to go further
as has been advocated by dimitro
in banning russian ships from our ports
in cracking down on russian banks
in going after new industries
filling putin's war chest like gold
and agreeing a clear timetable to
eliminate our imports of russian oil gas
and coal
we also need even more weapons of the
type the ukrainians are asking for
the uk is supplying more including next
generation light anti-tank weapons
javelin missiles and star streak
anti-aircraft systems
and last week we hosted a donor
conference with our allies to secure
more
the fact is that being tough is the only
approach that will work
putin has escalated this war
and this approach is vital to ensuring
he loses in ukraine and that we see a
full withdrawal of russian troops and
ukraine's strength hand is strengthened
at the negotiating table
there should be no talk of removing
sanctions while putin's troops are in
ukraine and the threat of russian
aggression looms over europe
we need to see putin withdraw his troops
we need to see ukraine's full
territorial integrity restored we need
to see russians
ability for further aggression stopped
we need a plan to rebuild ukraine and we
need justice done at the international
criminal court
dimitro we salute your bravery and the
bravery of the ukrainian people
we are determined to help in whatever
way we can
we will back you unwaveringly in your
negotiations
and together we will not rest until
putin fails and ukraine prevails